hey guys how's it go this is Jenna hi
this month is a huge month for gaming
not only the PlayStation board is out
right now but Xbox is coming out next
week and I'm actually gonna do an Xbox
one giveaway so stay tuned for that
sorry the giveaway is it for you I know
I'm not wanted I was just so excited I'm
actually really excited how are you
doing Jen I'm good
I thought that I would invite you and my
Google glass to help me open up this
PlayStation well we all know you're not
good at opening things so exactly okay
let me just get this goo closer okay
glass oh
okay glass record a video no it stopped
record a video record a video it doesn't
like female voices you have to talk
deeper I don't understand why but it
does okay I think we're ready ready yeah
oh I want to see a first-person
perspective of opening of it yeah okay
okay the thing is I'm not looking at you
I got real life I'm looking at you
through my mind glass eye is this videos
about the places since it lets unbox are
you ready yeah can you see oh look
somebody thanks forever they're gonna
have a PlayStation 5 out okay let's do
it
come on oh I want to know what it looks
like you want me to get scissors do we
need them there's like I mean we
probably should because there's a good
chance this might not work
PlayStation having some issues oh
there's been a lot of consoles ship gen
that have not been working yeah almost
cut myself that's a necessity no I just
got it okay here we go
oh nice
here's some directions wait okay like
direction I hate oh it's a touchscreen I
know
well earbuds oops Christmas yeah it is
okay we got our earbuds right here um
good power cord HDMI micro USB to know
about rat rat rat Drag City would you
like me to remove the box
yep take it away Jack you should take
the box it doesn't work there's a big
issue
who's my order somehow it got cancelled
on Game Stop I don't know what happened
they were so sweet today and they hooked
it up and we've got it so I've still got
the putter hi look at it
smell it miss smelly plastic
it smells like real smells like fun
smell fun actually doesn't smell smell
this one Shawn
this one doesn't smell it smells like
rope on it smells just like the other
ones what's it taste like you should
like it do you want to taste it first
taste it first I guess any time right
one two three it has always really
what's your side tastes like plastic
you really gotta get in there I did
maybe your side was tasty I don't like
my Germer did you lick up here hahaha I
want to look somewhere else like where
maybe like this the rough surface what's
it taste like
okay it tastes like nothing no there's
an after plastic taste
mmm you have to take my just husband mom
okay well that my friends is the
PlayStation 4 unboxing I remember where
the PlayStation 3 came out me and my
friend cool waited 24 hours in line at
Walmart so I'm officially waiting in
line for PlayStation 3 Dejan name is 852
be freezin I'm freezing
by Walmart yeah I wonder what the Xbox's
oh I bet it tastes like candy
I bet it's sweet like sugary treats do
you think anybody who you think there's
another Google glass PlayStation
unboxing who also likes the play that's
it for this unboxing I hope you guys
enjoyed it
I didn't even burn anything we burn the
Furby I've been trying to burn that for
years you want to even the little Bart I
don't see a lighter let's save this for
another video
cuz I have a feeling we should do some
it's real burning um
look at me I'm shaking my head you can
see the Google glutes okay alright
that's great
make sure you guys check out Jana's
channel what's your channel Jenna uh
it's me Jenny
it's me gang Stewie actually I think it
might be my name now because I use
Google+ I don't know no no matter don't
care see you guys later I'm gonna go
play kills them
Oh